e aí galera vocês quem assistir o canal
está tudo bom com vocês é que comigo a
zaga estava marcando então se tá silton
amará vinho eu quero que vocês estejam
também e aí galera que a regional tudo
com você e eu estou aqui existe agora
estou na presença da nossa dona irene e
que todo mundo conhece a gente está aqui
na casa de gabriel oliveira e eu estava
pensando nesse dia sobre uma questão de
relacionamento sabe como era namorada na
época da silva deixou na minha época a
gente namorar era de pedrinha balão pede
a joão féder já belinha se ele quisesse
namorar com a gente aí vamos barrar a
pedrinha de volta jogamos jogada e volta
pra gente aqui na ilha do amor se chegar
pegar na mão o padre emergência em rafah
e respeitei para que esse pagamento de
mão valeu já que o povo site chateada no
time é da organização não é que paga se
e como é que a menina usava roupa
antigamente é a roupa que caminha que
será razoável no chão em cima do joelho
era famosa ficava nos joelhos e ela
shopping é de esquecer uma volta
cumprida é a luta já extintas o debute
no shopping não choca nuvem só um jogo
quer dizer que não tem agora já estou
bem
que barulho quem chegou a se cumprir a
saia tem que ser cumprida
só quem é tudo besteira do povo que um
primeiro de roupa não é quem guarda a
nota
eu já que hoje é assim hoje em dia que a
meta é chegar em casa é ouvir a menina
ia conversar e tal foi a pedir pro pai
hoje em dia só você pega o número do
celular da pessoa é pronto já era
exatamente já está na marca a idéia é
fazer a chamada antigamente era o rapaz
chegada de sete da noite na casa da
namorada de 9 hora embora hoje em dia
com você chega de 11
chega de onagawa almoço da raia pra fora
o nep chega de sete da manhã só deu só
pra deixar né só trabalha agora em nada
aí podia aceitar namorando com fortunato
fica fora fica até não chegou a dizer se
não ficar na minha e é esse negócio de
ficar ou escolher ea apple não morava o
pai do bebê que esse e porque assim a
gente namorar em conhecer a pessoa
antigamente não conhecia o fogo não
chega né e enchia porque se você namorar
com a música que quiser se casar com
essa eu sempre pedia a mão dela em casa
- o pai dava e quando não dá você roubar
e com barba e embora com ela e ainda
refinar o testemunho é passista um dia
ver que você não ia fazer nada demais
com um aí hoje em dia se você consegue
ponto namorada
sei lá destino levar pra nada né agora
sim é que hoje minha conjunto com nove
anos a sair de casa nem mesmo estava
buscando minha 19 anos não sabe fazer um
café e mas já sabe sair na rua rafael
jataí e elton já a ficar sabendo que vai
ser só tenho um negócio assim é um
problema sim pra mandar mensagem uma
mensagem
só que ao mesmo tempo a gente pode
mandar mensagem para mandar foto pode
mandar vir a mudar porque não quiser
mandar eu quando eu quero saber o acordo
da internet quer botar ainda não sei
quando vai bullying computador tanto é
que essa não é muito legal nesse negócio
de celular e internet na eu sacava para
a internet no celular
nesse tempo eu já ficou pra ficou assim
conhecida que todo mundo fala num
arranjo
quero mesmo é quem eu sou casada ânsia
mercado é graças a deus meus fala em
respeito e amor e sabe que eu também sou
uma velha e uma velha que eu exijo eu
respeito todo mundo pra todo mundo isso
a taxa tem que ser assim mesmo ninguém
respeita é que eu vou me respeitar e é
porque você é jovem é mais difícil era
em receber canal e
a turma cachorro lá aí vem é ver o que
dá um bom que eu acho é essa nessa
brincadeira esse programa tudo que eu
que o brinco mais um um pouco com o
cobre é o respeito porque eu sou
respeitada da criança o velhinho eu vejo
por que quiserem respeitar e energia que
novo é esse 14 é promover o respeito
sempre puxa montar a peça humana se você
chega lá em casa o nome com esse gosto e
chega tudo que tinha então você tá
pedindo respeito ana se você chega
fazendo cachorrada brincar e então vocês
estão pedindo que o que a pessoa faça
com você o que você está fazendo é
melhor porque se você quer o respeito
primeiro você respeita a acontecer então
brincar com pessoal tem que entender
quando a brincar e man
então aí não sei não gosta da
brincadeira não querer caminho é verdade
eu estava falando que eu estava falando
com o povo aqui que quer que por que
aqui vêm anda devagar em cima de
calçadas na verdade eu não sei
a gente não quer passar e eles ficam a
derrogação porque vocês sim entender o
vai na calçada você quer passar eu eu eu
fui chove e amarram em geral
depois chito verba de varrição tinha que
acaba eu já falei com o minc que que vem
venha a respeitar se eu tiver no meio da
rua e falar a gente acorda estão batendo
com a gm pode amá lo agora será assim é
hora de aproveitar e falar a gente
também rouba mesmo que não tenha ninguém
roubando todo mundo o vai ajudar
o velho é hora porque vem aqui nem cria
cv
você já foi criança um e toda criança é
respeitada
o respeito é paga presente eu tenho um
ajeitar que nessa conversa aí a conversa
significa conversa no ct sempre vai
começar a vender uma criança se
respeitar aquela criança em ter meu
assim é o velho o velho a agitar uma
turma de velho assim é chega um jogo
jorge israel vem chega a ong deixei
minha namorada porque eu fiquei porque
eles senão vai deixando leds e respeito
é isso aí você já comenta quem fez isso
pinto que deixou de fazer
já com uma pessoa da sua idade exata né
e houver conversa com o verbo é época
tiver como é por exemplo a quando era
não namorava
então na época um novo não conversa de
correr de novo na frente do bar é não
houver conversa da conversa não é só o
zé é vender agora a iaee linha da safa
muito é o zagueiro é que aceitem velho
hoje não todos e nem eu acho é ridículo
isso não ajuda mas quem vê que tem 90 80
anos mas só que esse show é não se joga
bocha e mulheres temos quedas e falar
até porque isso já é velho eu só vai
ganhar frisou é a gota coisa e se ele
veio uma menininha passado e nem ensaio
uma boquinha porque já fica de olho
mesmo assim entende já fui jovem se
fosse no meu pé em ottawa pois é essa
daqui é dona irene lá e mossoró do canal
que é isso e se você quiser saber aí o
canal do que está bem que na descrição
do vídeo pode ver e foi muito bom gravar
com essas a falar meu nome é universal
o inglês acertou melhor que a minha avó
minha avó falou wilson wilson bill
wilson em nada de ruim de são nunca saia
da merenda primeira saída ao gent em
willians
uma pessoa legal ai gente nem querem
gostei
se gostou cliques e não gostou clinton
nesta casa e continue twitter e calma
nessa hora
começa aqui embaixo que você achou do
vídeo como é que que é sua relação com a
sesap se você conversa muito com gente
mais velha como é que aí minha rede
social está aqui na descrição do vídeo
vão sair ver a sala da dona irene é só
você clicar aqui o link aqui na casa dão
direito a receber uma aula dela e é isso
aí
valeu galera pro teste até aqui falou
que mandaram a sua entrada pra você
haiti sem a carne
essa é ó ganhar a panela